(clapping and cheering)
- It's so nice to see you!
- It is nice to be seeing...
- Real people.
I know.
- First, like, it live
talk show that I've done,
since, like, March of 2020.
We all know what happened
and there was a whole thing.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you guys missed or not?
- we're still getting
through it aren't we.
- Still, slowly but surely.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Well, we love your wife,
Ryan, as well on this show.
- As do I.
We love your whole.. that's good,
- Yes, it works out well for me.
- But, no , it does work out,
but what's funny is I
heard that everybody was,
like, giving y'all props
for 15 years of marriage,
but you've actually
been married for longer.
- I've been married for
almost 16 years in March.
- Okay.
- We eloped,
thank you very much, appreciate it.
- We eloped.
- So nobody knew?
- Nobody knew.
- That's the best eloping
- It was easy, you know, what I'm saying?
And then we got a chance to throw a party
when we were ready to have that party
and have everybody celebrate with us.
- 100 percent.
- The best story is, when
we got married 16 years ago,
things were a bit more frugal,
than they are for Brown
in this current time,
to God be the glory, to God be the glory
and we went to Santa Barbara
and we stayed at the Montecito Inn
and said, "That's my wife, oh my gosh."
- Y'all look so sweet.
- (both laughing)
We went and stayed at the
Montecito Inn And then I said,
"we wanted to stay at this
place called Bacara if...
- Oh yeah.
- Fancy resort in Santa Barbara.
She like, "We can't, we
don't got Bacara money,
but we'll go
and we'll do dinner."
- Balling on a budget.
- Exactly, we'll go have dinner there
and we went and stayed at Bacara
and was like, "This place
is really nice," right?
So for the 15 year anniversary,
which was just this year
we stayed at Bacara for four nights,
like a ocean view and it
was really really wonderful.
- That's so great that feeling of,
like, you were there before, I love that.
- To be able to return and be like,
"Yeah, we got a chance to do it, right."
Oh my God, that's so cool.